mesdames messieurs bon dimanche
Christian félin de ménager les attentes
depuis déjà quelques semaines la mise à
jour économique de jeudi n'affert aucune
surprise modeste mélange de mesure
ciblées d'intervention ponctuelle de
programmes aussi destinés à aider les
Canadiens plus durement frappés par
l'inflation le ministre des Finances
navigue entre prudence optimiste et le
risque bien réel d'une récession à court
terme et si elle fait le choix de
limiter ses dépenses et même d'offrir un
premier calendrier de retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire depuis l'arrivée
au pouvoir des libéraux les critiques
n'ont pas mis de temps à se faire
entendre c'est du réchauffé
chinois le réchauffer gouttmaya mais il
y a rien de il y a rien de nouveau dans
l'énoncé le gouvernement qui est promis
d'être là pour les gens à tourner les
dos aux gens pour le coup de chauffage
le coup d'épicerie contre qui continue
d'augmente d'augmenter la
séraphinflation ou l'inflation au départ
laverie sur la cupidité cette stratégie
m'inflationniste
augmente les taxes sur le chauffage le
sens et les épiceries donc les
consommateurs seront debouts pour les
Canadiens et nous allons voter contre
cette stratégie inflationnelle
[Applaudissements]
Christophe bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ça m'a fait plaisir
qualificatifs pour décrire l'énoncé
économiques que vous avez déposé jeudi
quel est le qualificatif que vous
utiliseriez pour décrire votre énoncé
une équilibre entre une approche
compatissante et une approche
responsable vous aviez quand même un peu
de marge de manœuvre et vous il y a des
gens au Canada qui sont durement frappés
par l'inflation qui attendaient des
mesures supplémentaires et qui sont
déçus de ce que vous avez déposé
il y a des mesures il y a de l'aide pour
les gens qui en ont le plus besoin
aujourd'hui
mais la chose la plus importante que
j'ai encé je dis c'était que les checks
pour la TPS vont arriver aujourd'hui à
11 on ne savait pas que ça arrivera
aujourd'hui et c'est 11 millions de
ménages et je dois dire Daniel que je
pense que pour une ménage qui recevra
500 dollars
ça fait du différence et la chose
importante c'est que le chèque arrive
aujourd'hui mais il y a aussi l'aide
important pour les étudiants et aussi
l'aide pour la location canadienne pour
les travailleurs l'aide pour les
travailleurs les moins payés ce sont les
gens qui ont vraiment besoin d'aide et
ces quatre,2 millions de Canadiens c'est
beaucoup de gens pour la dame dont vous
parlez près de chez vous qui va acheter
son bacon à côté parce qu'il est temps
spécial vous pensez que vous avez fait
toute la différence que vous pouvez vous
pouviez faire
je ne peux pas dire et je ne vais pas
dire que j'ai fait toute la différence
mais je pense que
c'est autant on va faire une différence
je pense que cette femme va recevoir le
tps 500 dollars pour sa ménage je pense
que cette femme va recevoir la location
canadienne pour les travailleurs c'est
2400 dollars pour une ménage et je sais
parce que je connais cette femme je sais
qu'elle a deux enfants ils seront aidés
par l'aide que on a envoyé aux étudiants
vous avez vous vous avez vous-même dit
que les la hausse de revenus du
gouvernement c'est une hausse de revenus
ponctuels anormal vous avez quand même
choisi de la dépenser dans dépenser la
moitié est-ce que c'est prudent
au début que on a choisi à une approche
équilibrée d'une côté je suis d'accord
avec les premiers questions que vous
m'avez posé que il y a des gens au
Canada qui ont aujourd'hui besoin de
l'aide et on a donné du l'aide mais
d'autres côtés on a décidé de ne pas
dépenser tous les revenus on a décidé
d'utiliser une moitié pour aider les
gens une autre moitié pour réduire nos
déficits aujourd'hui cette année à le
Canada aura une déficit de une virgule
trois pour cent c'est le déficit le plus
bas dans le G7 et j'ai une bonne
nouvelle à partager c'est que après que
j'ai déposé les noms techniques de
l'automne
à réaffirmer le code de crédit du Canada
triple A c'est une très bonne nouvelle
parce que ça dit que une agence de
crédit dit que notre position fiscale
est responsable que le Canada a de
l'argent
quoi qu'il arrivera du côté d'économie
mondiale on a de l'argent à la position
fiscale qui permettra le fédéral d'être
là pour les Canadiens vous venez
d'évoquer la question du déficit pour la
première fois depuis 2015 vous avez un
calendrier de retour à l'équilibre en
budgétaire vous parlez d'un budget d'un
budget équilibré d'ici 5 ans mais quand
même est-ce qu'il y a là-dedans une
réponse au discours de Monsieur
poirievre en face de vous dans la
chambre
il y en a qui disent que c'est ça vous
le savez
pour moi je prends les possessions qui
sont nécessaires pour les Canadiens les
gens que j'écoute sont les gens comme
cette voisin qui a parlé avec moi les
gens autour du pays avec qui j'ai parlé
pendant le thé ce sont les Canadiens qui
sont le plus important pour moi et
pourtant
je dois dire Daniel et peut-être ce
n'est pas une bonne chose à admettre
mais je ne suis pas très politique je
prends une approche
j'essaie je sais de parler avec les gens
j'essaie d'être à l'écoute et j'essaie
de trouver le bon chemin pour le Canada
et aujourd'hui je pense que ce qui est
nécessaire pour nous c'est une approche
équilibrée une approche qui d'une côté
est vraiment responsable d'autres côtés
est vraiment compatissante et vous avez
parlé
à surplus que on prévoit dans notre
scénario de base mais c'est important
aussi d'être franche à d'être honnête
avec les Canadiens on a eu aussi une
scénario plus pessimiste
et c'est pour cette raison que la
responsabilité fiscale est si importante
parce que il y a beaucoup d'incertitudes
dans l'économie mondiale aujourd'hui et
quand il y a des conditions
d'incertitude je pense que la bonne
chose à faire c'est être prête et le
Canada aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts
le mot récession est mentionné 13 fois
quels sont les risques qu'on frappe une
récession d'après vous
je vais préciser une chose notre
document
ne dit pas que on aura une récession
c'est ça noir sur planche et c'était en
tensionnel parce que on doit dire la
vérité aux gens c'est une on a une
scénario plus pessimiste et c'est dans
cette scénario qu'on dit que vraiment on
peut avoir une économie à qui ralentit
beaucoup dans le monde et aussi au
Canada
pour la technologie propre hydrogène
vert c'était pour rivaliser avec les
mesures qui ont été adoptées par
Monsieur Biden aux États-Unis entre
autres est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que vous en avez fait suffisamment pour
garantir le maintien d'investissement
ici peut-être en attirer davantage
oui et je veux souligner aussi que ce
n'est pas que hier notre gouvernement le
gouvernement de Trudeau a découvert
l'importance d'action climatique c'est
une des thèmes clés pour notre
gouvernement du 2015 le Canada est une
des leaders mondiales en ce qui concerne
l'action climatique et dans chaque
budget notre gouvernement a investi
beaucoup dans la transition verte on l'a
fait en 2021 on l'a fait dans le budget
américaine ici on a fait du plus parce
que on comprend que les autres pays
en découvrit que on doit réagir le
Canada est là et je veux faire une
promesse et c'est que dans le budget en
printemps on va faire encore de plus et
un dernier mot sur l'impact de la taxe
de 2% sur le rachat des actions des
grandes sociétés c'est problème c'est
criant pour vous est-ce que est-ce que
c'était nécessaire d'aller là et à quel
point ça va avoir un impact d'après vous
j'espère que cette axe va encourager les
grandes entreprises à investir dans la
productivité canadienne à investir dans
le Canada à investir dans ses
travailleurs et qu'est-ce que vous êtes
à ceux qui disent vous avez pas taper
sur la tête des pétrolières des
épiceries qui enregistrent de gros
profits depuis le début de la pandémie
qui encre enregistre encore de gros
profils pour pour qui les Canadiens ont
le sentiment que font un peu d'argent
sur leur dos
cette taxe est ciblée sur tous les
grands entreprises incluant ce que vous
avez juste mentionné
merci à vous